el mundo vive una nueva suerte de
carrera espacial ya no se busca alcanzar
la luna sino obtener una vacuna contra
el 19 es una guerra de laboratorio sobre
la que la organización mundial de la
salud pide serenidad using vaccines us
global usar las vacunas como bien
público están en el interior de cada uno
de los países el nacionalismo de la
vacuna prolongará la pandemia no la hará
más presa la o&m se advierte que no van
a respaldar la vacuna hasta que se
demuestre que es segura y que esa vacuna
nuestra lista para una distribución
masiva hasta mediados del próximo año
pero desde la casa blanca hay otro
mensaje el xbox de ayer fire
acabo de hablar con el director de facer
gran tipo anunciaron que esperan tener
resultados de sus pruebas muy pronto el
próximo mes pero muy pronto
permaneceremos en el camino para
distribuir la vacuna antes de fin de año
e incluso antes del primero de noviembre
november first antes del primero de
noviembre es decir antes de las
elecciones y si las cuestiones de tiempo
entonces rusia tiene la delantera su
ministro de defensa probó la vacuna
experimental de moscú
la espuma 5g este viernes fue elogiada
por la revista lancet tras ser probada
en 76 personas es un medicamento que ha
demostrado una respuesta inmune con
anticuerpos pero eso no es suficiente
según algunos expertos
hay que fuera del tiempo posterior a que
una inyecta un líquido que contiene ese
virus atenuado o modificado para ver si
primero genera los anticuerpos segundo
si esos anticuerpos se mantienen en el
tiempo por lo mínimo de tiempo ocho
meses aunque hay entre 6 y 9 candidatas
en fases avanzadas la única certeza
según la ong es que cuando estén listas
tendrán que aplicarse con prioridad es
esa parece ser otra batalla en el
horizonte